dislocated shoulders sleeping on set and
fake blood that taste like one of your
favorite home cleaning products what
other embarrassing things did actors
have to deal with on set keep watching
to learn all the mortifying details
christopher mintz ploss got his first
acting gig at the age of 17 in the
awkwardly hilarious coming-of-age film
superbad written by seth rogen and evan
goldberg the critically acclaimed comedy
focuses on three friends played by jonah
hill michael cera and mince ploss the
three friends are a mere weeks away from
their high school graduation as their
senior year nears its end they attempt
to attend a popular senior class party
and hopefully lose their virginities in
the process due to legal reasons
regarding his age at the time of filming
men's plos revealed that his mom had to
be present on the set of superbad while
he filmed a sex scene i'ma need to see
some identification
really
makes me feel young again
luckily it sounds like it wasn't a
terribly troublesome experience for the
actor a couple of years after the film's
release mints plos explained in an
interview with the guardian it was real
awkward but it worked out okay because
when i watched the movie with her the
sex scene wasn't awkward because she'd
been right there when it happened
makeup and prosthetics are incredibly
important when making abiopic let's be
honest it's easier to transform an
actor's physical appearance to resemble
a subject instead of improving an
actor's overall performance even if they
happen to look like the person they're
portraying makeup wins at being the
easiest solution
of course all that makeup can come at a
price
thanks to behind the scenes featurettes
viewers can hear all about how laborious
the whole makeup process actually is
for example while talking to
entertainment tonight renee zellweger
detailed how terrible her experience was
while filming judy the 2019 biographical
drama about the final year of judy
garland's life zellweger was required to
wear a prosthetic nose tip along with
false teeth during an intimate kissing
scene with her co-star finn wit rock the
tip of her prosthetic nose fell off
after it fell off it covered her co-star
in a white liquid emitted from the
artificial body part fortunately this
error didn't ruin her experience as a
whole while making the film and she
eventually went on to win an academy
award for her performance
everyone has had moments during long
work weeks where their eyes begin to
droop and they'd love nothing more than
to take a quick cat nap on the clock
rapper and occasional actor gucci mane
seems to have felt the same way while
filming 2012's spring breakers in an
interview with vulture he recalled the
long working hours on set in addition to
the touring he'd completed around the
time he was filming the movie
unsurprisingly the artist was absolutely
exhausted and actually fell asleep
during a sex scene director harmony
corrine told the huffington post they
were in the middle of shooting the
intimate moment when all of a sudden he
heard snores coming from maine's way the
musician attributed his mid-scene
slumber to corian's extreme work ethic
claiming the director would work for 48
hours straight however karine contests
it was more likely due to gucci's
habitual weed smoking as for the truth
well we'll just let sleeping actors lie
game of thrones was an epic fantasy
series that left many of us with
awe-inspiring and gruesome moments
actress emilia clarke played daenerys
targaryen on the show and she appeared
in her fair share of shocking scenes for
example one of daenerys's most iconic
moments was in season one where she
consumes a stallion's heart and gets
covered in blood in the process
clark stated in a 2012 interview with
jimmy kimmel that throughout the course
of shooting that scene she ate
approximately 28 prop hearts made from
jam clark reiterated this messy
experience to vulture and added that the
hearts tasted like bleach despite being
promised they would taste like gummy
bears unfortunately clark's woes didn't
end there after so many takes clark was
covered in extremely sticky fake blood
the material was like fast-acting glue
and she actually disappeared from
filming because she had accidentally
gotten stuck to a toilet rest assured
being the mother of dragons is not all
it's hyped up to be
[Music]
it's hard to find a more intriguing duo
than leonardo dicaprio and margot robbie
in the 2013 film the wolf of wall street
the two play jordan and naomi belfort
for those unfamiliar with the film it
follows jordan belfort a high-profile
stock broker who makes millions by
essentially scamming the everyday
investor throughout the movie there's no
shortage of r-rated material so believe
it or not robbie was actually injured
during one memorable moment there's a
scene in the film where the bell forts
have sex on a mattress covered in cash
unfortunately all those fake bills had
some seriously sharp edges and by the
time they were done filming her back was
scratched to pieces talking with the
daily beast she said that when she stood
up the whole studio gasped and asked if
she was okay afterward robbie said she
pondered whether it would have happened
had the money been real
fans of the popular tv series friends
may recall the scene when joey suddenly
turns up in monica's apartment wearing a
sling in the show the explanation given
for the injury was that joey had injured
his arm jumping up and down on his bed
now all these years later we finally
know exactly how actor matt leblanc
injured himself it turns out filming the
part of joey tribiani was more dangerous
than you'd think talking with jimmy
kimmel leblanc explained that he
dislocated his arm in the season 3
episode the one where no one's ready in
this episode joey and chandler are
battling over an armchair and as they
were filming this moment leblanc wound
up in an unexpectedly awkward position i
was gonna land on my head between the
table and the chair so i put my arm up
to break my fall and just exploded my
shoulder this scene didn't end up in the
episode but it just goes to show that
even on a series like friends you never
know when a stunt might end in disaster
mrs doubtfire is a classic dramedy film
about a divorced dad played by robin
williams who comes up with an elaborate
plan to spend more time with his kiddos
he does this by cleverly disguising
himself as his ex-wife's nanny one of
the children happened to be matilda star
mara wilson in her debut feature film
while filming the former child star had
the sex talk with her mother and wanted
to tell everyone sharing the
embarrassing moment in her 2016 book
where am i now true stories of girl hood
and accidental fame wilson said i wasn't
focusing on the scene i was bubbling
with excitement because i knew this
thing this big open secret and i could
not keep it in any longer one evening
while filming wilson's mother had told
her about the birds and the bees she was
so excited the next day she walked
around the set singing a song about it
though the cast and crew found the song
hilarious wilson's mother was
embarrassed which also made wilson feel
ashamed however everyone on set tried to
keep things light director christopher
columbus even joked that they could
change a line of dialogue in the film so
that wilson could refer to another
character's dress as sexy
in the sci-fi thriller the adjustment
bureau matt damon plays a politician who
falls head over heels for a ballerina
played by emily blunt unfortunately
mysterious agents then conspire to keep
the politician away from the lovely
dancer while there's a lot of drama on
the screen there was also a bit off
screen as well blunt revealed that she
struggled maintaining the proper balance
for some of her dancing scenes in a
conversation with jennifer aniston for
variety blunt briefly spoke about a
specific incident that occurred during
the movie while answering a fan's
question regarding the most embarrassing
thing the actress had experienced on set
she recalled falling face first during a
take for the film despite a few bruises
the fall didn't ruin blunt's experience
making the film or her performance after
the film wrapped production she
attributed her recovery to all the
massages she received shortly thereafter
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one